[Music]
everest is an iconic place to be able to
search the changes this high up is
critically important to science once you
get to about 5,000 meters or around base
camp you are above where most of the
science on the planet has been done
the big goal of this expedition is to
collect scientific information about
climate change
what we're doing in assessing how
climate change is affecting species were
doing an elevational biodiversity survey
to identify all the species that live in
the environment based on the water
samples all right lake
all right
that should be good you want that hole
closest to the edge so you don't stand
there she'll be all right
by studying the species up here and how
they're adapting that might teach us
ways that we have to consider adapting
ourselves yeah
how far up on our planet Earth does our
human imprint reach and what extent we
want to investigate how this imprint
accelerate snow and ice melting so we
are collecting a bunch of snow samples
but we are also collecting detailed
measurements of surface reflectance
that box a lot it's at the top so many
life LaHood's depend on what's happening
upstream up high with the ice with the
snow the 20% of the world lives
downstream of these really vulnerable
glaciers here in the Himalaya and what
people decide to do downstream effects
high-altitude environments
to bring any change or any solutions
first we need to understand the problem
and what these glitches are going to
mapping is an extremely useful tool in
understanding across the glitchy and how
they are changing like a picture is
worth a thousand words if you have a lot
of pictures and you can create a very
illustrative map with lots of
information that is very very essential
to understand these glaciers and their
dynamics
what we're going to be able to do then
is compare Basecamp back into the past
and into the future
[Music]
and this gives us a super detailed look
at the ice and how it's going to be
changing and how it has changed
[Music]
[Music]
my role here is to collect ice core and
snow samples on the way up from Kampala
sure across there to go Icefall up to
8,000 meters it's possible nobody before
study ice cores from data elevation and
that will be new puzzle piece that
provide data and better understanding
what's happening
at higher elevations
[Music]
we want to know in real time what's
going on the bounty
the weather station sees a whole years
worth of weather possibilities then we
can use machine learning to provided a
totally different approach to how you
can forecast weather to have a weather
station where you're literally touching
the next level of the atmosphere is
critically important
the very idea that the highest part of
the planet has been impacted by human
activity ought to be a real wake-up call
[Music]
you
[Laughter]